Now I'd like to take a minute to characterize components.
They are pre-existing and
general, making them reusable in a variety of contexts.
The question arises, what does it mean to manufacture a component.
Well to manufacture a component you just have to copy it.
So the manufacturing costs are quite low.
You can configure a component with respect to your needs and target environment.
That is, there's a great deal of flexibility involved when you have components.
The components that property built can be easily composed with each other and
with noncomponent code.
Components conform to a software component model that prescribes their
syntax and semantics, and how they are composed.
We will look into example software component models a little later.